big news out of the Department of
Justice tonight
Attorney General Jeff Sessions
announcing that he will not be
appointing a second special counsel to
review the FBI's handling of the Russia
and Hillary Clinton probes in a letter
to three Republican congressional
leaders sessions noted that special
counsels are only appointed in
extraordinary circumstances and that
instead he's assigned the US attorney
John Huber in Utah to conduct a review
of the FBI's most high-profile cases but
first an Ingram angle exclusive earlier
this month jeff Sessions fired deputy
director Andrew McCabe of the FBI just
days before his official retirement
citing an IG report that concluded mr.
McCabe lied under oath and made
unauthorized leaks to the press the
public still hasn't seen that report
but joining me now are two men whose
offices have a copy of the Inspector
General's findings let's bring in from
Columbus Ohio Republican Congressman Jim
Jordan and with me here in studio is
North Carolina congressman Mark meadows
also republican so let's start with you
congressman Jordan what's the headline
that's going to come out of this
inspector general report well we don't
we don't know what will come out of that
but we do know about Andrew McCabe that
he didn't lie just once he lied four
times so four times he lied to you lied
to James Comey he lied to the Office of
Professional Responsibility and he lied
twice under oath to the inspector
general and remember this is Andrew
McCabe deputy director of the FBI
this is Andrew McCabe the text messages
between Peter struck and Lisa Paige
talked about Andy's office the meeting
where they talked about the insurance
policy in case Donald Trump is actually
president United States so that's why
this is significant and again it wasn't
once it wasn't twice wasn't even three
times four times he lied about leaking
information to the Wall Street Journal
about the FBI congressman meadows he was
adamant in his op-ed that his career you
know speaks for itself that he was
authorized to speak as he did to the
press and yet you guys are saying he's
lied four times well I I think it's not
our words is actually the independent
investigation that was done by his
colleagues and so when you read it it's
not about politics you broke the news
actually you broke the news right here
just you know a little over a week ago
now and what we're finding is everybody
saying well this is political in nature
but when you read the report you see
that it's not political because under
oath and and certainly with the
investigation it was a real problem but
but here's why it's critical here's why
it's critical you know the Attorney
General Sessions just talked about its
drawer Denari circumstances well how
much more extraordinary do you have to
be when you fire the central player in
the investigation that's that's one
critical component and so we need to
have this special counsel I I disagree
with the Attorney General and I can tell
you tonight I went through and reviewed
some redacted things that were given to
our committee and and on seven pages
there were 12 material facts material
facts not just names material facts that
were omitted by the Department of
Justice it's time that they come clean
and give Congress what we need 12:12
material facts what I'm talking about is
you know the news broke about the
meeting that happened with Denis
McDonough in the White House the former
former White House chief of staff for
Barack Obama that was redacted but but
it what it didn't stop there when we
look at the multiple reactions that are
taking place this Department of Justice
is not complying with the subpoena and
with the oversight responsibilities that
we have in Congress and so for the
attorney general to suggest that there's
not enough there there is just extremely
disappointing congressman Jordan it
sounds like your colleague is
congressman meadows is saying that I
mean there was a reason to redact
certain information because whether it
was a reference to friendship with judge
Contreras or perhaps with information
related to McDonough it doesn't make
them look good and it's right right
they've been trying to hide information
promised we have to go over to the
Justice Department go in the room and
have our staff look at this information
come back out and tell us it's
ridiculous but Marc is exactly right
when the Attorney General writes
Congress and says only under its
ordinary circumstances do we appoint a
second special counsel well how about
these facts Laura the james comey has
been fired deputy director Andrew McCabe
has been fired Jim Baker former chief
counsel at the FBI has been demoted and
reassigned Peter struck former deputy
head of counterintelligence has been
demoted and reassigned and Lisa page
former FBI counsel has been demoted and
reassigned if those aren't extraordinary
circumstances warning a second special
counsel I don't know what the heck is so
I don't know why the Attorney General
keeps postponing this everyone in town
knows we need a second special counsel
to get to the bottom of this how can how
can mr. Hubert he's probably a great
lawyer I don't know much about mr. huber
from Utah but how can he investigate his
boss rod Rosenstein that's who he
reports to mr. Rosen Stein is involved
in all this FISA abuse that we think
took place so you have to have a second
special counsel
I hope jeff sessions figures that out
and names one very soon this is what one
of your chief critics on another network
said under questioning let's watch was
there ever a strong case for appointing
a second special counsel no as far as I
could tell most of the accusations
against the FBI are lunatic conspiracy
theories just not grounded in anything
and and I think the Attorney General did
an appropriate thing here
congressman meadows well I mean when you
look at the facts the facts speak for
themselves Laura
when we're looking at is it a material
fact that Peter struck had a
relationship with a FISA judge and they
concealed it the answer is yes is it a
fact and we now know that the
investigation into Donald Trump started
late July within seven days there was a
meeting with the Department of Justice
where they said the White House is
leading this within seven days everyone
has to understand that I think a lot of
folks miss that when this happened the
other day that the White House is
leading well I mean that was in that
meeting we've got text messages that
would suggest that and then within seven
days of that we have a meeting at the
White House with the chief of staff of
President Obama saying you know we can't
draw a conclusion but we can certainly
look at the
and the facts do speak to further
investigation that's why we believe why
can't you bring McDonough and Frick well
I think I think that would be the
appropriate thing to do but it's not
just there some of the redactions that
the Department of Justice have they keep
the name so we don't even know who to
bring in and so it's important we've
just learned these things reason this is
from the text another text that we're
talking about tonight August 8 2016
struck to Page internal joint cyber CD
Intel piece 4d that refers to director
Comey scene setter for McDonough brief
right trainer head of the FBI cyber
division directed all cyber info be
pulled out let Bill and Jen Hammer
hammer it out first
though it would be best for Dee call me
to have it before Wednesday White House
session yeah and that Wednesday meeting
was was August the 10th we know that you
can go to the White House logs right now
and look it up Jonathan Martha was there
signed in did that so that was on August
August the 8th of 2016 we know that two
days later there was a meeting in the
White House so you know we're putting
the pieces of a puzzle together
but the DOJ or keeping some of the
pieces from US congressman Jordan I want
to ask you about a letter that was sent
today with congressman Gowdy and
Goodlatte they seemed to they seemed to
heap some praise on to the US attorney
he'll be looking into this invest into
these questions while we continue to
believe the appointment of a second
special counsel is necessary this is a
step in the right direction we expect
the US attorney Huber given his
reputation will conduct an independent
and thorough investigation what reason
do you have I guess he was an Obama
appointee but imagine if an Obama
appointee actually concluded that there
was perhaps even criminal wrongdoing
here that'd be pretty significant versus
look Council know it my guess is John he
was a great great lawyer is gonna do it
do a fine job but it's not a second
Special Counsel it's not a Special
Counsel and John Huber has to he has to
report to rod Rosenstein who's
in the application he signed one of the
prized application of course he did so
that's the problem and the simple fact
remains these are extraordinary
circumstances those top five people at
the FBI they were involved in we should
never forget this they're the ones who
put this dossier together dress it all
up like it was legitimate intelligence
took it to the FISA Court and didn't
tell the court the whole truth namely
who paid for the dossier and the fact
that the FBI had terminated their
relationship with Christopher Steele the
author of the dossier and they didn't
disclose that to the court so that's
those are all key facts that's why a
second Special Counsel is certainly
warranted under these extraordinary
circumstances for cases this big and
this monumental this consequential you
can't omit material facts you you have
to disclose conflicts apparent conflicts
the appearance of it it all has to be
disclosed otherwise no one who
understands legal matters at the very
least and many in the public will not
have a lot of faith in this
investigation that's just it that's just
that's how it works and legally it's
supposed to be crazy Lawrence but it's
supposed to be the truth the whole truth
not part of it not redactions when you
go to a court when you go to the court
you got to give them the whole truth
they did not do that at the FISA Court
and it was those people two of them have
been fired three of them have been
demoted and we don't think that's
extraordinary circumstances warning a
second Special Counsel I mean tell me
some fact pattern that that would then
mr. sessions the last word for you
congressman meadow why do you think Jeff
Sessions is so resistant to this well I
think he's being poorly served and when
you look at it when I've had
conversations with him and the Deputy
Attorney General it's almost like they
have a set of talking points that they
go to but the facts don't support those
talking points I would suggest that both
of them need to look at the defined
details of this and when they do they
will come to the same conclusion that
Jim and I have come to is it's time for
a special Rosenstein wants a special
counsel it's like what's good for the
goose is good for the gander on that
mouthing he wants it congressman thank
you so much for joining us tonight